Jesse, in the
past seven battles,
you have been faced
with fierce competitors
and you've knocked them all
out of this competition.
And if you win today,
will match the most
amount of money ever
earned in "Forged in Fire"
history, $50,000.
Your competitor
has two Gladiator
of the Forge titles of his own.
Oh.
Jesse, in order
to win the day,
you're going to have
to beat this guy--
[dramatic music]
GRADY POWELL: --Kurt.
My name is Kurt.
I'm a two-time
Gladiator of the Forge.
Now I get another
chance at beating Jesse,
and then he can feel
what it's like to have
a loss under his belt.
This battle will consist
of eight hours of forging
competition where you will
build one of these three blades
from our wall of
gladiator weapons.
Today, you're going
to need to build this.
JESSE (VOICEOVER): I
hope it's not a dolabra.
GRADY POWELL: The dolabra.
NARRATOR: The dolabra
was a versatile weapon
used by the Roman Empire army
in the first century and beyond.
Featuring a massive axe head
on one side and a sharp pick
on the other, the
versatile battle axe
doubled as a tool for
soldiers who would need
to fell trees and clear brush.
In the Colosseum,
the dolabra's ability
to deliver deadly chops and
lethal blows against an enemy
made it a favorite
weapon of the gladiators.
Bladesmiths, this is it.
This is the last battle in our
Colosseum-themed competition,
Gladiator of the
Forge, so good luck.
Your time starts now.
[rock music]
JESSE (VOICEOVER): My game plan
is to forge out this canister,
cut the canister in half
for the outer jacket,
and then forge out a 20-layer
random pattern billet,
and have that as a sandwich.
I'm setting up my San Mai so
that there's already a gap.
After I get this
entire thing welded,
then I'm prepared to begin
drawing out my blade.
After I get the axe
head shaped out,
it's time to go on to the pick.
This is not your
traditional pickaxe.
It's a recurved pick axe, so I
do that with my good old trusty
hand hammer and the anvil horn.
GRADY POWELL: Jesse's this
blade is looking badass.
Now with the blade pretty
much forged to shape,
it's time for the quench.
GRADY POWELL: There
we go, all right.
Jesse has his axe head quenched.
He still has to
get that pick done.
Boom.
Jesse has a fully
quenched blade.
It's great.
It's a little bit heavy,
so I can definitely
spend a lot of
time on the grinder
and make sure it's as
light as it needs to be.
One of the parameters
is a leather wrap,
so it's time to
give it some flair.
I want it to look
like a bloody mess.
GRADY POWELL: What
is Jesse doing?
He's trying to make it
look like it's bloodied up.
GRADY POWELL: How long does
that stuff take to dry?
Long enough that I'm
going to have red hands.
This thing looks so menacing,
even my hands look bloody.
Last thing I'm going to do
is put an edge on this thing.
KURT: This time I
go with 16 layers
because that's four less chances
of a forge weld not taking.
If I cut it up four
times, I'll still
have 64 layers total with that
1095 core for the same length.
All the forge welds took, so
once I get the length that I
need, I can cut it
up into four pieces,
stack it, and draw it
out to get the 64 layers.
Good.
Now that I'm confident
that the welds are good,
I can draw it out and then
forge weld the San Mai.
I see that some of the
welds around the eye
are splitting about
quarter of an inch.
I drifted the eye
walls too thin,
and there's a crack
going right down it.
I just want to do an edge
quench on the axe head
because if there
is too much stress
on that cracked
weld around the eye,
it could blow the
entire weld apart.
I'm hoping that this
heat treat goes well.
All right, guys.
We've got two bladesmiths with
two fully quenched weapons.
These guys are
seriously neck and neck.
Yep.
KURT: The last time that
I lost against Jesse, it
was because of the handle.
So I'm going a little
extra on this one.
Kurt's been spending a lot
of time with that handle.
Last challenge,
make it beautiful.
I finally have
everything put together,
and I am extremely happy now.
Hopefully, my weapon is
good enough to beat Jesse.
GRADY POWELL: 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, put
down your tools.
This round is over.
Good job.
It was fun.
I'm very impressed.
Gladiators to the forge, Your
dolabras look evenly matched,
but it's time to find out
what kind of lethal damage
they will do.
This is the kill test.
Kurt, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- I'm ready.
All right, let's do this.
[dramatic music]
Damn.
All right, Kurt, let's
talk about your dolabra here.
First up, it is razor sharp.
That dummy is going to have
a headache for a long time.
Now, using this on
that ballistics dummy,
it is amazing.
Every thrust with your
pick, here, penetrated this
because the balance you have
here allows for nice thrust
and delivery on that.
But during the test, you
lost a section right here.
One of the layers
from your blade right
here didn't weld
all the way through.
But looking at this,
your core is still solid.
So it's still going to be a
functional and testable blade.
And overall, sir, your
dolabra will kill.
Thank you, Doug.
Jesse, you ready?
All right, let's do this.
[dramatic music]
All right, Jesse.
Let's talk about
your dolabra here.
First up, you have a
heavier blade here,
but it serves it very well when
you're doing damage like that.
The feel of the weapon
really allows it to go deep
into this ballistics dummy.
Overall, sir, your
dolabra, it will kill.
Thank you.
[dramatic music]
All right, gentlemen.
You know what time it is.
It's time for our strength
test, the Roman armor
and shield chop.
And Kurt, you are up first.
Oh, destroy it.
[laughs] I can't wait to.
[dramatic music]
That was pretty cool.
So Kurt, this is a
good-looking weapon.
The leather wrap you
did and the texturing
up on the handle actually make
it quite comfortable to swing.
The issue I have is
this delamination.
[clank]
It's come further open.
It didn't affect
using it at all,
but I do worry that that's going
to continue to be a problem.
All right, Jesse.
You're up.
You ready?
Sure.
[laughs]
[dramatic music]
[forceful exhale]
All right, Jesse, right
off the bat, great look.
It's a good shape.
The pattern came
out really nice.
And where it really stands out
is right there on the socket,
which is kind of cool.
You still got an edge.
Everything's right and tight.
Everything's solid.
All in all, it held
up beautifully.
Great job.
Thank you.
You had fun, didn't you?
Well, Jesse, Kurt, I
couldn't have asked
for a better final match-up.
But at the end of the
day, only one of you
can take home that final title
and the last check for $5,000.
The Gladiator of the Forge is--
[dramatic music]
--Jesse.
You are unstoppable.
Now, Kurt, you should
be proud of your work,
but unfortunately, your
dolabra did not make the cut.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
- Thank you, gentlemen.
GRADY POWELL: Thank you, Kurt.
Jesse, congrats, man.
You deserve it.
Thank you.
So Jesse took another title.
And I don't disagree at all.
He once again turned
in an awesome weapon.
Kurt, you did a good job, man.
KURT: Thank you.
Chin high.
Well, Jesse, I've got
one word to describe you,
and that is "impressive."
You just won your eighth
Gladiator of the Forge title,
and you have $50,000
to take home with you.
Congratulations.
[applause]
Thank you.
This experience was
definitely once in a lifetime
I just won 50 grand.
I'm planning on putting so
much of it into bladesmithing.
I already made a spreadsheet of
all the tools I'm going to buy.
I'll finally live
the dream, as opposed
to just dreaming the dream.
[music playing]